- He's an entrepreneur,
motivational speaker,
television personality, and author.
He turned down a career in
accounting to focus on sales,
and now teaches others the art of selling.
He's the author of five books
and has his the New York Times
and Wall Street Journal Bestseller lists.
He's Grant Cardone, and here are his
top 10 rules for success.
(loud swoosh)
- Hey, I want to talk to
you today about success.
Success, duty, obligation, responsibility,
if you approach it any other way,
which most people are, most people think,
"Well, I'll be successful
if the economy works.
"I'll be successful if something happens.
"I'll be successful if I
win the lottery ticket."
Look, you're not going to be
successful if you don't demand it.
If you literally don't
stick a claim to it and say,
"This is mine. It's important,"
you're not going to have it, I promise ya.
I know. I'm telling you from experience.
I spent the first 25 years of my life,
like a spectator watching
other people get successful,
and then wondering why I wasn't.
Success is your duty.
It is your obligation
and your responsibility.
Almost 90% of sales managers
say that they don't have time,
you know, and again, it goes back to,
look, if you knew it was
going to bank you money today,
would you make time
for it? So, they would.
They would make time for
it 'cause they make time
for the things that make 'em money.
If you have a customer,
hopefully, if you have a customer,
and you're working a
deal with that customer,
and you got a hamburger in front of ya,
hopefully you're going to
push the hamburger aside
and work that deal because
the priority is to make money.
In the same conversation,
that sales manager
does not believe that,
sales training converts
to, or allow our money,
so he doesn't make the time for it.
When you say you don't have time,
the truth is you're saying,
"I'm not making it a priority
"'cause I don't think it makes me money."
So, you want to get
your work ethic so high
that people actually admire you.
I'm going to ask you a question right now.
Do people know you because of
your unbelievable work ethic?
If you can't answer yes to that man,
you're not going to get in that top 10%.
You got to get to the top.
People have to know you, not because,
"Oh, he's a good salesman.
Oh, he's a good this.
"Oh, he's an artist.
Oh, he's a good pianist.
"Oh, he writes a great, you know, story."
No dude, people need to know
you for one major thing first.
He works. He produces.
The guy's there everyday.
The guy's pushing and
shoving because the truth is,
no matter how good your ideas
are or how good your art is
or how good your skillset is,
if you're not working, man,
if you're not vibrating at
a frequency that people say,
"My God, how does that guy do all that,"
if you're not vibrating
at that rate, 10 X levels,
massive action, tremendous
work ethic that's just
the muscle now, and it's just
a discipline in your life.
It's a way; it's a normal way
that other people think is abnormal.
Ryan Seacrest, Tom Cruise,
Oprah, Steven Spielburg,
Donald Trump still pumping
and working as a billionaire,
look, if you're not working at that level,
you're not going to make it;
get your work ethic in, man.
It's the American way.
Work ethic! Check it out.
The biggest struggle, man,
was just getting around
the people that would say I could do it.
I mean, that's the biggest struggle, just,
you get around one guy who
says, "Yeah, you can do it,"
and then you talk to him
tomorrow, and he's like,
"Naw dude, it's freaking,
he can't do this yet."
You know, there's so few
people telling you to do it.
You know what there is a
lot of? Save your money.
Protect yourself. Conserve.
Don't spend. Don't take risk.
Taking risk is the new
way to be risk-adverse.
So, the biggest struggle
for me was my family, man.
The people closest to me
was the biggest struggle.
Every time I went out to do
another deal, everybody told me,
"You don't need to do that, man."
The only person that was
encouraging me was my twin brother,
'cause I would see how he was doing it.
Dude, he was making he's swings,
and so, every time I'd
get around other people,
so, I'll tell you a little trick I did,
on weekends, I would always go
see homes I couldn't afford.
That has always inspired me.
I would go look. I would
go drive neighborhoods.
Literally, I've done this my entire life
until I finally got to the point
where they wouldn't even
let me in the neighborhood.
There's neighborhoods in Miami,
dude, you can't even go see.
They won't even let you in the gates.
Most of 'em you can get in if
you know some of my tricks.
(laughing)
So the point that Shovita's
writing on the board
right now is you got fuel in your tank.
It wants to be accelerated
on, and then you got somebody
in the backseat saying, "Hey, be careful."
Nobody likes a backseat driver, okay.
So, they're sitting there.
They're putting mental
pressure on the brakes,
when you're trying to accelerate.
The negativity is just negative,
and there's no money in it.
There's no future in being negative.
Where's the solution?
You know, "I can't do
that. We can't do that.
"That can't happen. This is wrong.
"That's wrong. Oh my
gosh, taxes are too high.
"Taxes are too," dude, it's negative.
It is negative. It is negative!
Look, there's so much
abundance in negativity,
that, by itself, tells you
why there's no value in it.
You got to make a commitment to service.
You got to make a commitment to
like, "Hey, I have a target."
I know that when we don't achieve
targets here in my office,
the first thing I ask, regardless,
the Internet Department,
if its my Accounting
Department on collections,
or its my Sales Department, and
I'm going to ask a question.
What is the target? No
target results in no sales.
So, if you're in parts,
if you're in service,
look, have a target.
Measure that target
hourly.
If you really want to get
results, measure your target
every hour to see, what do we
get in the last 60 minutes.
I promise you, do those two simple things.
Don't even learn anything about how to
sell anybody anything.
Have a target, measure it every hour,
and I guarantee your sales will come up.
Within any company I have, I own,
I have four and five
flows in every company.
I don't have one flow. I'm not
going to depend on one product.
Once I get those four streams
coming in from one company,
okay, for instance, at this company,
it's an online project
called Cardone University.
Then, there's speaking
gigs. Then, there's books.
Then, there's audios. There's MP3s.
Those are flows coming in for one company.
At some point, I'm like,
"Okay, let's do a second deal."
So, I'm going to then have a
company that runs parallel,
like a skier, right.
I don't want the skis crossing over.
I want them to be parallel
so that anything that maybe
I can't do any longer in this
company, maybe I'm going to
outsource to a partner and
building a second company.
Then once these two are
skiing along and happy,
maybe I'm a go do a third company out here
that I have a passion for,
that has nothing to do
with these first two.
That is not diversification.
That's multiple strong
flows, and when I make a bet
on this third company, dude,
I want to take all the money
from these first two
flows, and I want to say,
"Hey, if it's a good deal, go all in."
If you're not sure, don't put
any money in it at all folks.
And there's so many
mistakes salespeople make.
I think you need to get down
to, like, the main ones,
but you're selling the solution.
I mean, even before that,
though, I would say,
(mumbles) is the biggest
mistake. People are not excited.
They're not alive.
They're not showing interest in the cycle,
and they lose interest.
I was in,
Barcelona recently, and
I looking at a watch,
and the cycle didn't close.
I could've bought the watch.
I was qualified to buy the watch.
I'm the one that walked
myself in the shop,
on my vacation to look at the watch.
I knew exactly the
watch I was looking for,
and when I left, my wife said,
"What could he have
done to close the sale?"
I said, "Well, he could've
kept life in the cycle.
"He could've kept the cycle open."
So, what I mean by that is, look,
if you're not interested,
if you don't believe
the cycle can be closed,
it will not close.
So, the number one mistake
I think salespeople,
managers, and the store
makes is they assume
a close can't be had that day.
I go into every cycle, every sales cycle
with every prospect,
every phone call, every,
no matter how complex the
sale is or how simple it is,
with the belief that I can sell
that product that day, this time, now.
Hey, work to your
potential, not your quota.
If you want to stay really motivated,
if you want to answer the
question to why people
that have already made it keep pushing,
it is because they
don't operate on quotas.
They operate off potential.
They're driven to reach their potential.
This is also tied to
their ethical obligation.
They know what they're capable of.
Nobody can tell you
what you're capable of.
You're the only one that knows.
Okay, so work to your
potential, not your quota.
Quotas are numbers. Who made 'em up?
Some guy says, "Okay,
your quota is blah, blah,"
Okay, based on what? How do
you come up with that quota?
He only picked that quota, or that number,
because he thinks it's
significant, or compared to
other people, maybe, in your industry.
Look, don't operate on
quotas. You want 'em.
Clearly you want 'em, but you
want to be driven to reach
your potential, not just
some numbers, some mechanics.
Hey, my potential, I know.
Nobody else knows it.
I know what it is. You know yours.
Work to your potential, not just a quota,
and I promise you, you will
be on fire, day and night.
Hey, Grant Cardone, I
just want to give you
a little encouragement
here on Thursday afternoon.
This week, I have been
in Detroit, Buffalo,
New York City; I was
on my way to Hartford.
It got canceled because
of some situations.
Whoa! I just dropped my bag.
Why am I telling you all this?
Okay, now I came to the wrong terminal.
I'm having to walk back to two.
I'm not asking you to feel sorry for me.
I'm doing this as a encouragement video.
Dude, things don't go right.
You got to push harder.
You got to spend money
that you didn't think
you were going to spend.
Hang in there. Don't quit.
Do not quit. Push.
Okay, I know how hard it is.
I know it's hard.
I know there's moments
where everybody thinks,
"Oh my God, what am I doing?"
Just keep pushing. Your
family needs you to do it.
Your community needs you to do it.
God bless America. It
definitely needs you to do it.
So, hang in there. Keep pushing.
When you think about
quitting, just understand
that everybody that you compete with
is having the very same thought.
Last man standing, baby, man or woman.
Thank you so much for watching!
I made this video because
Chris Waller asked me to.
So, if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave
it in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do,
and I'd also love to know
which of Grant's 10
rules most apply to you
when you're going to go
and take action on them.
Leave it in the comments. I'm
going to join the discussion.
Thank you so much for
watching, continue to believe,
and I'll see you soon.
(loud swoosh)